you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens on everybody welcome back
out to the game spot co-op stage here at
e3 2016 hey everybody i'm craig from
ScrewAttack joining us right now it's
Xavier woods AKA austin crossed agreed
yeah i'm up up down down up up down down
it's my youtube channel go subscribe
check it out if you haven't already it's
fantastic you are phenomenal promoting
its outstanding crying with it I learned
from Greg Miller on this stage last year
actually that's extremely fortunate i
hate do you think this isn't it raid and
of course if danny who is ro is our
anchor today sure you're the anchorman
no no no i'm the i'm the drunk Irish got
on the ship while you're holding some
shots we should do him right now it's a
great and very i'm really impressed if
you're drunk right now you don't look at
it or not I'm actually dry for like
months really yeah stands you and a half
months thank you get married in July so
I said I'm not gonna drink until then
and then I'm gonna drink a lot but
that's gonna bet my back fire you might
you might forget your wedding day no I
might turn back in Ireland and then
start checking my brother out by like
two pints let's talk about something
that makes you feel like you're drunk
while you're playing it let's talk about
me it's about VR virtual reality all the
rage hero theory we have our white
boards outs because we're gonna do a
little bit of ranking over-excitement
who I'm gonna name off few games you
guys can aim awesome games as wall ha
hey I'll join in too if you guys have
some stuff so we're gonna break our
excitement based on just general levels
once again rankings to me personally are
fairly arbitrary they don't mean a whole
lot you can be 1 through 10 it's all
about the substance of what you're
talking about or select your gender give
me a smiley face you can be mashed
potatoes it doesn't matter just whatever
you want to rank it right so let's talk
about some games us we're going to start
talking about sony VR specific okay okay
sony of the arca they said october 13th
is when it's coming so fourth quarter
this year just a few months away
exciting right before halloween dance up
and there's gonna be they said 50 games
between launch and the end of the year
that excites you so many games yeah the
thing so i'm excited about the
PlayStation VR because I've got an HTC
vive at home and it's like the greatest
thing I've ever
purchased and I was like I see I'm gonna
be cool because I must be like the
oculus and everything but obvious at the
time like no controller so you're just
like watching videos right but the vibe
oh I finished the dungeon crawler and
I'm legit in my house and my having a
party with my friends and we're like
falling over the couch and everything
like trying to fight overs and blocking
swords and stuff and so the fact that
we're get to have that on PlayStation as
well like oh like I don't know how I'm
gonna just sit with a regular controller
anymore after experiencing this because
it's too good so have you had like
friends over because you're like five
parties yet legit had 12 weeks ago so
what's it like when like you have some
but do have any friends who just like do
not play games yes so what's it like
when they put on so we put them into uh
what's the audio shield it looks like a
dancing ddr type rhythm type game and so
you hold an orange shielding a blue
shield orange bubbles come at you blew
bubbles come at you took welcome to the
music and so she's literally like
doesn't play games at all we put the
headset on her so that oh I like that
Rihanna work song and so we found the
remix and so like it's the speakers in
my house is playing she's getting into
it like Oh videogames are sweet and so
it might be a good way to bring people
into games that don't necessarily play
game at sounds a good workout hear you
well so here's the thing right we have a
pull up right now if you once again if
you're watching on the ScrewAttack
youtube channel there we are if you
wanted on ScrewAttack youtube channel we
have a pole right now and the poles very
simply vr is dot dot dot the options are
the future of gaming okay a nice
addition to the gaming market hmm
something I may check out later or the
new 3d TV I think we all know how they
3d TV ended up right so I'll let you
guys make your decisions on that and if
you want to make your decision you can
as well just vote in the corner hip a
little I button in the corner up there
and you'll get to you on yes Austin
Xavier what what do you what do you
think VR is a gift from the gods Wow
just come from the heavens above and
they have graced us with virtual reality
as you just stand there in the VR helmet
thumbs down on your head it's so good at
one point there's a game I've got called
fantastic contraption and it's almost
ice yeah if you played The Incredible
Machine back in the day it's like that
you're just building
things to complete objectives but as
people watch they can say oh no put this
wheel here attach the stick there and
like it's so completely immersive that
it's like it's hard to put into words
you just can't explain how good it is
until you actually play it because i'm
watching people play it um I don't down
a couple of videos on my channel up up
down down go subscribe on YouTube um and
it's weird cuz like I don't get sick
watching it but like I don't feel the
same way watching it because like
normally if you're playing a game
obviously there's a static screen you're
moving the camera but VR your head is
constantly moving when you're looking at
things in the real world so when VR it's
the same thing yeah and so it might not
have the same feeling watching them on
screen but when you actually got the
headset on and then you got the
headphones on as well you're completely
immersed in this world that's what video
games are trying to do for us anyways
completely immerses so with this whole
new experience it completely changes the
game for everything and that's a muscle
problem i have for like trying to get
the word out look we were talking
earlier about the we write the weave
when that came out they straight up hot
like sets and malls forget come over and
play I'm the cool thing about
playstation vr is like a lot of people
already own a ps4 oculus and vibe
they're like really expensive so unless
you got somebody unless you have a
friend who like spends a lot of money on
games like we do you're not gonna be
able to get that experience yeah
PlayStation VR I mean it's still four
hundred dollars natural level but it's
easier for people to get to hopefully
that'll spread the word yeah you talk
about like the what Nintendo had to go
through to kind of break down the
barrier of okay yes this is a we silly
you what this sounds different and this
is why you need it in your house right I
don't think there is that with VR it's
but it's pretty simple like you put this
thing on and you're in a world right I
think pretty much everybody pretty much
understands that because this has been
talked about for decades I mean you go
back to virtual you know the virtual boy
right people know that you put something
on your supposed to be immersed by so
yes I know a virtual void oh man yeah
exactly the matrix like its existing
sci-fi for decades you can go to Disney
World and go to the carousel of progress
and there's a little boy playing games
of the VR headset on that was done in
1955 always knew yeah it's crazy this is
a father always been the next thing ya
that's crazy I can see you town cuz he's
floating like this your your pole answer
VR is
d 50 games out this year on PlayStation
also maybe a porn app oh no the porn is
coming I will help the porn is another
nap will help I mean 50 games coming in
2016 that's what what you need is if
you're gonna spend four hundred dollars
on something you need to have enough
games out there to like make it
worthwhile but also porn might say okay
not to not to speak on that but you can
windows live just use your desktop right
what's the headset on and make things
full screen with that phones on and with
that information what you will I mean
just get you've heard about God I've
heard yeah i read it on run read it
somewhere there's so much information
editors yeah let's go discuss you guys
are they always doing crazy things
because my response is VR is simply just
Blair alright like this not not that not
that like I think VR that's me throwing
up I don't what are you throwing up is
that a kind of like a cloud but it's
just a bunch of vomit flying nimbus yeah
yeah I just I'm not a good drawer when
I'm trying to host the show so but when
you're when you're not know I'm right
brick in Mozart are Martin Mozart it
starts like a law making music that look
like it's crazy man it's just lines and
I see numbers and stuff but yeah for me
vr I've I said I played it quite a few
times every VR experience to me has got
me nauseous in some way shape or form
I'm not a motion sickness kind of guy
like when I'm up in a building some
people are really weird about that I am
afraid of heights right what but just
being so immersed in that thing well not
physically being able to touch it to me
that kind of sets me off in a weird way
and at most i can do maybe 20 maybe 30
minutes before I really start feeling it
right so I think that for me is gonna be
a big barrier and I think we are
something that I'm skeptical of mainly
because I think for me gaming is
something that I when you sit down you
play a game you are playing the game
you're checking your phone you're
looking at a guide you're doing whatever
just don't stare their screen anymore
right second screen third screen things
that are happening and I guess
technically you could have those second
and third screens inside your headset
with you but then that takes away from
the immersive it yeah right and that's
why I think it's cool about it cuz to
that point like you are fully emerged so
you can't check your phone you can't
check this guide like you're in the game
and I feel that's something that we've
definitely strona way from with the guys
and all the term stuff so i think that
the cool experience is that vr is not
taking over gaming it's just another
aspect of it so you can do that and then
you can take the headset off and then
play a game with your controller on the
TV so it's a cool option for people that
do have the the means to get it or they
have like a vibe party or playstation
party but like you said you get motion
sick I think three-fourths of the fun
would be our is watching other people
play VR ya in person cuz it's hysterical
and like there's not a dull moment and
you feel like you're in the game because
you're there playing it and they're
freaking out and screaming it's it's fun
all around cuz sometimes it's not fun to
watch people play console games you know
yeah but be are totally different as
somebody who owns one right and you like
make the time to play our games there's
some games right that I need to like say
ok I've got three hours free like The
Witcher right I can't forget a bit rich
for 20 minutes I need to be like okay
I'm where I'm gonna do it yeah so what
VR games do you find that you are like
waiting until no one's in the house are
waiting until you know no one you know
delivery person's gotta come is there
like this sort of anticipation to play
it or i mean are you just popping it on
I'm just popping it on right now because
a lot of the games that are on Steam
there they're good some of them lengthy
games there's a game we were playing
pool and you can play multiplayer and
like legit there's a microphone on your
computer like I didn't know it's getting
into multiplayer and a headset budget
pops up like in the bar next to me is it
ready to play and like what you really
feel like there's another person there
but if there's a delivery guy coming
like I literally played with like one
headphone I you know I don't know I feel
like eventually there will be games that
are like that where you need to be fully
immerse for a long period of time but
right now I feel like there's the games
are so geared towards making sure people
understand how to use virtual reality
that that's not too much of an issue
right now I think that's the one thing I
think I don't think with VR you're gonna
see like the 15 to 20 our story ethics
because i feel just for me personally
all out though right sure sure but paula
is also a game that you can sit down and
play for 15 or 20 minutes 30 minutes
then set it back right yeah because it's
your adventure you can do what you want
but I I don't think you'll be able to do
that with because people won't be able
to have that long extended play period
you know Louise like that's yeah they
follow will we adapt I don't know yeah
like I'd pollinators again that whenever
I sit down and play it I tend to be like
three hours later like I mean I'm it's
also a game that when you're playing it
on the screen it's so immersive that you
do feel like oh I'm like oh I'm back in
my living room in oakland okay like it's
i feel like i actually went somewhere so
i mean it's it's just as weird frontier
where I don't know like will I play via
and fall out and and spend that same
time will that still feel like three
hours because that's the other thing I
keep hearing is that like spending 20
minutes and vor kind of feels like
closer to an hour it's time goes away
completely rip e because there's there's
no clock in there if you're playing by
yourself with the headset on like
there's no it's like you're in a casino
in Vegas yeah I was gonna say yeah can
you wait can you like wait until draft
kings or insert casino offs or betting
happens here and watch it real time then
over here people will be so oh my
goodness that just proves you're pulling
levers but that's the thing that I think
so the first time I tried it out oh my
brain toffee video games are going to be
the smallest aspect of this right once
they get the technology exactly how they
was there there's going to be doctors
teaching people how to do surgeries with
this you're gonna be able to test drive
cars there's an ikea game where you can
like lace shelving something awesome you
can finally set up a room and then buy
it night here like your earrings are
gonna be the smallest aspect as much as
people get used to it that's not to like
get the ikea so far ahead as a look yeah
wrong shade yeah cuz there's a camera on
the front of it so i can you take a
picture of your room oh I'll put this
furniture here put it there like well
this looks nice click x on your your
paypal and then they'll bring a couch to
you tomorrow like you ever do you guys
use the oculus touch demo no that's the
one that they show where I think they've
only ever shown it to a certain price
but it's the one we have the to oculus
controllers and you're basically talk
kind of like the pool thing you're
talking to somebody else and throwing
things and all these objects and it was
really weird cuz i did this demo last
year at Gamescom and i was playing with
this guy like throwing things at each
other and catching it in all this and
while we were doing that we kept
high-fiving each other mmm and then
after the demo i was talking to palmer
luckey and this guy walks over and he
was like oh i'm the guy was you were
playing with he was in like two rooms
over and he went to high-five on a
high-five Desmarais thinking about it i
was like oh we've never actually high
fight before yeah that was all like fake
digital land
and I thought man like my niece's live
in Ireland I only get to see them twice
here I thought man that felt like play
like I want to do that yeah I wanted
like socialize that way so to your point
like maybe that's the new skype maybe
it's just this set apart oh I I have a
buddy who develops for the vibe and the
way he described it was faced with
oculus gaming is gonna be like twenty
percent of what they do and right and
eighty percent whereas with the vibe
it's like eighty percent in twenty
percent social on it with that obviously
PlayStation VR its PlayStation right
yeah all right so look at the porn it's
actually let's just talk about our
excitement level for these things right
the actual games we can rank him however
you want to rank ok give me 110 a
thousand mashed potato spaghetti
whatever you want you like that much
potato I love mashed potatoes cuz I mean
we're all the master dedos an I'm from
Texas we invested all right let's talk
about Batman V are you you are Batman
for the first time you are looking
through Batman's eyes you are seeing it
you are seeing the Joker right in your
face you're in Arkham you're surrounded
by it how amazing is that dan you're
ready mmm what I'm not violate oh my god
fan I don't care really spider-man thing
I just don't like I love the Arkham
games they're cool they're great right I
don't want to be back because I like I
do I have to speak like their stall time
ago you do ok that's the rule yeah ok
then been eight eight out of ten just
saying like that Dave here hahahaha oh
man yeah so you'd rather play Superman
that's coming off that of course do I
want to fly in virtuality yes or
spider-man Batman fantastic but he's
like he's like a buzz lightyear like
falling with style kind of thing going
on uh and and I'm with you I'm with you
I don't want to talk like this have you
played that game there's a viewer game
with the hooks where you're like hooking
onto things I don't know even played I
saw it I saw good so that's like
spider-man got a commando is it we are
swinging and I so spider-man made me
think oh yeah a good Oh where's our
wizard what you're inking my old mine I
didn't get on yet my wreaking was bad
NVR is a scowl out of ten just got this
it's good I can we can we be Alfred in
the game I the second player right at
the old sailor outfit yeah dude can you
bet what do what if there was a VR game
where you just played as the assistant
the entire time on the plane yeah I
would love that because Alfred's the man
in this in the newest one Batman
Superman they're just like old drinking
buddies and there's two old hammered
dudes the whole movement like I can
totally get behind us alright next game
probably one of the most exciting
announcements at sony resident evil 7
all right I'm really into project diva
oh he's gonna see it over the hill my
favorite games on vita my bed come to
ps4 to okay sorry sorry sorry won't you
did you might have seen amiga live let's
let's see if you let's see if you're as
excited for resident evil 7 as you are
for that did you see the did you see the
demo for that you did yes what did you I
guess we'll find out cuz i plated I was
really immersed by it it made me want to
pee my pants a little bit and by a
little bit i mean a lot I was terrified
I'm a giant weenie when it comes to
those games and I'm probably gonna start
a let's play channel just because that
game exists so good Tommy's lost any
weight and undies Oh undies I'm gonna
mess up my pants playing the game it's
very scary just I got I got terrified
playing the first resident evil with
like the really good graphics uh so with
this man being in a world where things
chitters it on the screen like I love
watching horror movies good bad whatever
yeah um to being immersed in one like
this feeling here in this old house
seeing all these things happen man no
you know it's too much which I love it I
love so yeah actually gonna be
incredible I cannot wait to see you play
yes on on the sony BR on your channel up
up down down which you can subscribe to
right now I need to Danny would let you
Brazil sandwich in VR yes yes I'd like
they're going back to Resident Evil One
like we talked about it earlier Reggie 6
was a bit of a nightmare as if I was
like an action game for was great mmm
but it was a different type of horror
yeah rezi one is like this real like
medias like you're peeking around the
corner type of horror I feel like I
haven't had that in a long time in
Resident Evil so it's great it like it
is it's a whole you know PR line it is
both entirely new but also like back to
its roots so I'm really excited for it
cool cool on a next game this is a game
that was not expected go BR but a game
that a lot of people have been
anticipating I'm talking about Final
Fantasy 15 yar now the trailer for this
was pretty cool I don't know any of the
characters but it's all the guy with all
he turned around gave them gave the wink
with a thumbs up with the VR helmet on
that's pretty exciting JB are you are
you a pic final fantasy guy huge Yahoo's
what was your favorite final fantasy 7
is by far like he's probably greatest
game of all time to me really materia
system the characters are the story the
bought everything in that game is
absolutely perfection to me you know
they didn't even talk about the remake
dude oh hi yeah why they brought it up
last year I was waiting for like oh the
remake also gonna be in VR like oh so uh
this is gonna make me cry tears of joy
tears of joy because i love final face
of 7 i'm a very avid player of final
fantasy 14 still like now forever I've
loved playing online everything so it's
gonna be amazing because I play the demo
and it's so good alright it's very
different and it's more of the active
battle system like a kingdom hearts how
style of deal so to be able to do that
in virtual reality again to swing the
swords to press buttons and do magic
like feel like you're in it it's like
like your LARPing in your living room
have you ever warped before I look for a
living actually wanna get technical
that's good anyone about you and please
ya know there's this whole thing with VR
right where they're going to be doing a
lot of Victor sighed dlc it's it's like
it's a VR experience tacked on and I'm
kind of coming or NTID that that's okay
like if every game just does this little
package like we know this thing's gonna
be free when you buy the game it's going
to maybe come out after he said a couple
of months I was interviewing guys
yesterday said a couple of months
afterwards we'll get it up there and you
know what if you're gonna spend five
hundred dollars on this and every major
release just even those that little tiny
thing like okay let's make that happen
for every game I mean resident evil is
amazing cuz you go game but I think
that's cool I think it's a nice tip of
the hat so did
every gamer regardless of what series
they like feels like they're involved in
VR in some way let's go to the last game
on my list of uh this specific well I
got two more games let's talk about
let's talk about Minecraft BR ok we are
my and the friendly updates the friendly
update that they made with realms and
texture packs and it being cross
platform and stuff mainly VR though does
MINECRAFT VR gets you guys excited being
immersed in a world of Legos essentially
and being able to build as you see fit
I'm real bad at minecraft I could be bad
at minecraft or horribly bad because the
whole premise like I don't know I feel
and this might be way too long of an
answer as generations come after certain
generations I feel like their
imagination grows like exponentially so
I feel like our generation all we had
like duck tales and swat kats all these
sweet cards with our imagination is
blowing people out of the water but then
this next generation of kids comes with
Minecraft and like that oh we have no
objective we can do whatever we want and
I feel like for us like I want to know
like when I hit 50 coins i get an extra
life when i do this stage i unlock this
sword like with their with their
generation they can just do whatever and
they love it and so for me it's not the
best game for me because I I'm just bad
at building things and making a house
and I get killed by the zombies and
stuff but I think for those kids and
those people that do play minecraft it's
absolutely unreal because now they've
gone for building these worlds and on
keyboard on controller however they've
seen fit now they can be in the world
that they've made and they can interact
with people in that world that they've
made and it's almost like a what's again
second life right yeah second life
experience put it in a Minecraft setting
so I think it'll be really cool for
everybody loves those games cool Danny
hey well actually reminded me of was
Austin talking about the ikea thing
again because like what I love doing a
minecraft was was building out houses
and I mean it changed and they're like
oh I learned how to make glass now I
have to tear down everything and make
glass but the reality of playing
Minecraft now is that like I turned 30
couple of months ago and whenever I play
online I feel like it's me and thousands
of younger people who are better at the
game than me so say you're the old guy
just kind of standing at the playground
looking out of a play going all day like
yeah they look like they're having fun
and they're better at this
I am the best thing I ever made
minecraft was I made a huge Christ the
Redeemer that God vomited lava and this
was about four years ago and since then
minecraft is like exploded in like in
the much lower sort of age range so I
kind of feel like it's awesome to doing
this but it's for them and I hope they
have a blast with yeah but I have a
whole generation of like carpenters and
architect rice but I'm nervous about all
of the New Age architecture or
architecture II what's would put some
architecture architecture or just all
the buildings are just square ready pick
up the later than have you seen that
commercial is like a car commercial
where everyone's squaring it it's good
it's like well that's kind of weird the
real life let's go hold on to our final
game uh someone that I'm most excited
about I don't know about you guys cuz
this is pretty cool alright i'm talking
about star wars battlefront vs the idea
of getting in your x-wing flying it
around shooting at everything that moves
and being able to look in any direction
we've seen games like was that something
Eve there's a VR game I'll curry yeah
you've got yah where were you flying
around but you're not in an x-wing is
you're not in a y-wing right elite
dangerous is another kind of one lots of
that and in italy i'm not a huge star
wars guy i know that's sacrilegious i'm
not a huge star wars guy but you know
what that excites me just the idea of
getting and being a part of that ya know
it's pretty cool but i miss the stuff on
that is there gonna be a single player
campaign now well they they just said
it's happening I didn't say anything
okay the longest sort of it is you get
in you're getting your x-wing wiling
whatever it is right you fly around
you're not you're in dogfights right and
you know you can think about you maybe
you go down to the trenches or something
I don't know that that's got to be
something they do I'm in if you can play
Aslan yeah he's by far the greatest
character in star wars universe all than
sexy man no Calrissian if I can play is
Lando you got me you play as Lando I
mean come eat whoever you want when your
VR right true okay I don't know some
time to look them up my hands yeah I was
hands don't look like my hands oh so
curious yeah touch with us put on gloves
make it a not too specific to be the way
that get over like it'll be like the
sort of representation in games like a
Strix it'll just work everything you
know
it's you it's fine you're covered hi
Danny what about you man star yes x-wing
I like x-wing vs. TIE fighter all these
games I grew up playing with like I love
battlefront was fun it was kind of
simple like it's sort of a very I don't
know accessible version of that and
that's cool cause like you know game
should be accessible for a lot of people
but I feel like you know if there was
one game that could definitely do with a
remake that virtuality would bring it to
that next up because those games felt so
immersive I waited you know we forget
now we have all these 3d World is that
like they were doing some crazy math to
try and make it look like it was 3d back
time you know you don't think I'm to do
with Star Wars they need to remake Star
Wars arcade the one where you had the
dimer there and to say that make that 3d
so good dude I'd be no good totally
remake there is a game where you uh
train blocking lasers with your
lightsaber oh yes on vibe so like if
they just bring that old ass bring it
over here a little bit more okay
podracer bring back hot race yeah
that'll be so good oh my gosh there's so
much you can do in the Star Wars
universe and you know what they're gonna
do it they're you know they're gonna do
then it could give you tiny hands yes
you know you're the kids hahaha how do
you grow your hands get a Harrier hear
that awesome brings up a good point
alright we have to finish date took
older games and revamp them for br oh
yeah like I don't know if you have never
played this uh gunstar heroes of course
okay gunstar heroes in VR kid chameleon
River City ransom chameleon was built
around beings right but yeah actly row
your trash do to be so awesome just take
these new games or old games it just
redo them VR I'm totally a Gila you guys
want to start a VR development company
and make motorcycle fight I'm in its own
only if we can what saw what was it aah
mutant league Oh force games yeah mutely
cool then you know they're making a new
one what yes they're making a new way I
not know this yes oh my god did you go
google it its go k magic worms in VR
you're like a little worm it's crazy I
could talk forever sweet this is this
exciting stuff will dude Xavier woods a
Kaos agreed yeah youtube channel up up
down down go subscribe if you haven't
already yeah we're here now where we go
boom that TVs that one but yeah
subscribe up up down down you look it up
check it out not as actual VR I think so
much for joining us Daniels with this
all day coming up next we're going to be
getting into a little killer instinct we
have the developers here we're going to
be talking about the brand new character
the gears of war care if you're coming
in appreciate you guys two min will be
back in just few minutes what you guys
hold on keep watching there you go in
just few minutes here at coming Ron I
that's for the games out east off stage
30 2016